[Música]
si aquí en pensilvania continúa ese
recuento de votos muy lentamente para
que os hagáis una idea desde las 7 de la
mañana hasta ahora que son las 5 de la
tarde sólo se han contabilizado un 1% de
las papeletas
porque el por lo que los resultados
podrían tardar todavía en llegar varias
horas además aquí en pensilvania esos
papeletas que han llegado por correo con
fecha anterior al día de las elecciones
pero que han llegado después del día 3
de noviembre no se han empezado a contar
hasta este mismo momento aún así a las
puertas de este centro de votación en
filadelfia la imagen es ésta trampitas
serios expectantes porque ven que a su
líder se le escapa la casa blanca de las
manos y sobre todo después de que aquí
en pensilvania el demócrata joe aire
nieve una ventaja
alrededor de 13 mil 800 votos y justo en
el lado de enfrente seguidores de joe
biden que celebran de manera anticipada
lo que ellos creen que es ya una
victoria dicen que casi acarician esa
victoria que casi la acarician esa
llegada de su líder a la casa blanca
justo en medio de ambos para que no haya
ningún problema agentes de la policía
que no se pueden mover de aquí porque
cuando lo han intentado ha habido
enfrentamientos entre ambos bandos así
que se quedarán aquí hasta que esto
acabe para evitar que se repitan estas
imágenes de tensión esos disturbios que
hemos visto en otros puntos del país